All right, welcome to the DDPS seminar. Everyone,
Before we introduce our invited speakers,
let's go over some rules and logistics, not many.
First, please mute yourself during the talk,
but if you have questions, you can unmute
and ask questions, or use chat room to
post your questions so that we can address
them in Q and A session at the end second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to external
audience. Please, no classified these questions,
and today's the talk is going to be recorded and
available in Youtube channel in near future. Okay,
that's about it now. Let me introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host Professor David
Borge, who earned his PhD in 2002 with HD banks at
North Carolina State University. He was a postdoc
at the University of Michigan in mathematics
and joined the faculty in applied math at the
University of Colorado in 2006 the core of his
research interests are weak form based scientific
machine learning and inverse problems at the
intersection of applied math and statistics.
His research has been supported by NSF, NIH,
DOE and DOD. Today, David will talk about a
first principles approach to understand, no, no.
Sorry, not that he's going to talk about the weak
form is stronger than you think. All right. Now
let me pass the button to him, but before that,
let me ask a somewhat informal questions to get to
know him better. My first question to David today
will be, how have you ended up where you are right
now in terms of career, research and work, etc?
Well, thank you very much for the nice
introduction. Young Sue, in answer to
that question, it's been a bit of a meander, so
to speak. I started out doing inverse problems
as an undergrad. I went to do optimization and
computational fluid dynamics, and then I kept
trying to figure out what I really wanted to do
in terms of I knew I wanted to do applied math,
and eventually I ended up doing mathematical
biology because it seemed like the questions were
very messy and interesting that could benefit
a great deal from bringing more mathematics
and applied math computational methods to bear.
And so I went through the standard career path,
got a got tenure, and about the time I got tenure,
I started looking back to see what had frustrated
me. What had, you know, just inhibited progress.
And the thing that struck me was in biology in
particular, there, when you would create models,
which model was the correct model, you know,
just parameter fitting, forward solver based, you
basically guess a parameter forward solve iterate
your least squares function. And so I just kind of
got to thinking, let's try to think more about the
computational methods and the mathematics behind
like the nature of model selection as well as
you know, system identification and so eventually
ended up working on this. This weak form approach
is where this got. It basically came out of being
frustrated, of trying to fit parameters to another
biochemistry or bacteria model and them not
working. And this particular method that we have
come up with, and this approach that we have come
up with has a surprising number of applications in
many different areas, and has really helped answer
some important questions that have in system
identification. They've sort of been elusive for
a while, and so it actually has applications that
are much broader than than biology as this is
why young Sue we've been talking is they seem
to be relevant in computational plasma physics
and such, and we just order modeling there.
Nice, nice. I mean, your your frustrations
led you to a wonderful world. It sounds like
it's worked out pretty well. Yeah,
nice, nice story. Okay, well, the
stage is yours, okay, alright,
okay, well, thank you again for the invitation
here. So what I'm going to talk about today is an
area of. Applied Math computational methods that
has really it was something that was a part of
the initial flowering of scientific computation
and scientific computing that began in the 50s.
Specifically, where some of this comes from
was the aerospace engineering literature,
where they were, of course, trying to identify
parameters very fast, to for the for the new,
the new at the time, of course, the jets that were
being being created. And so what, what happened
was there was a strategy for parameter estimation
that was proposed and eventually discarded,
and the reason it was discarded is fascinating,
and there's actually some interesting parallels to
what's going on today, in the sense that where a
lot of the system identification went was this the
direction of let's try to solve the differential
equation, or the stochastic differential equation,
in some way, and then We can compare with data and
use that process to estimate parameters. This is
sort of a there's a positive feedback loop here
where you need a bigger computer, you need to
come up with more algorithms. There are perhaps
more knobs to turn and more tweaks to make to get
all of these pieces to fit together. But then, of
course, you would like a bigger computer so that
you can do more of these computations. There's
actually a very realizing the other day. There's
actually a very strong similarity to the way that
some of the neural network literature has gone in
terms of, there's more knobs. You need a bigger
computer, et cetera. And so what we're doing
here is we're going back to the basics of stuff
that was developed in the 50s and 60s on system
identification with the benefit of 70 years of
numerical methods, computational methods, advances
in statistics as well as, you know, parallel
programming methods. All of these seem to come
together in a way that wasn't available back when
these methods, they were originally created. And
I will, and I'll get going in just a second. But
it's just the the overview of the core of what's
happening here is based upon the weak form. So
we all, we've all heard about the finite element
method. That's a standard method for solving a
differential equation. And the the way that what
we're doing here is, in essence, taking the finite
element method, but instead of trying to solve for
the equation, we look at it from a different point
of view and say, What happens if we substitute in
the data that we have, and then try to estimate
the parameters? So it's sort of the reverse of
what you would normally think of with a finite
element. So that's, that's the core. Everything
follows from that, that concept, and that was
originally proposed in 54 and and basically no
one was working in this area by the end of the
century. And so this is what we've, we've sort
of unearthed here. Okay, so briefly here. So Dan
is the the who's a graduate student with me, and
this, a lot of this work originated from what was
in his dissertation. And so he's sort of been a
collaborator from day one on this direction here,
and then the research that we're doing. And then,
of course, we have, April is another graduate
student in the group, and then Nora and Rainey are
two postdocs. Vania is another faculty member in
the department who has computational statistics,
who's been heavily involved in this also since
day one. And then Seth and Nick and Moy are so
Seth and Nick are new graduate students in Moyes
and new postdoc but these are people that sort
of CO advising and working with other people on
and all of the, by the way, all of the codes and
everything that we produce the results in here,
if you're interested, it's in the math biocu
Direct on GitHub. The project there, though,
it's kind of gone far beyond being math bio,
but that's the what we have. Okay, so let's, let's
sort of dive into what we can do here and why this
is compelling. So just as an example, I'm actually
gonna give you the punchline first here. So here's
the Coronavirus efficiency equation. Okay, this
is a, well, I don't know if it's super well known,
but it is a an equation that comes occurs in
like laminar flame fronts. There's applications
in plasma physics, but it is a particularly
challenging one to just to deal with, of course,
because you can immediately see you've got four
derivatives. You've got a non linearity here.
It's challenging. And so if, just as an example,
if you took this system and you this was the data
you had. How in the world are you going to be
identifying these parameters to make things
worse? You can actually prove that this is spacio
temporal chaos. So any slight numerical problems
way over here at time zero are going to cause
you big problems by the time you get to over
on the right side, right it's just going to it's
going to blow up on you. And you really want to
identify these parameters, minus one, minus one,
minus one, right? How do you do that for these,
these complicated problems, if you have data
like this? Well, normally, we think about
fitting solutions to data. You can do some
filtering things, but at the end of the day,
you're still worried about matching the solution
to data. Of course, you have to worry about your
numerical discretization. There's a knob you have
to turn. Learn. Maybe you could train a pin to do
that very fast and do operator learning. Maybe
you want to. And generally, in the 50s and 60s,
they would call this minimizing the output error.
And now we just think about this as matching. You
know the solution for whatever w you come up
with as a parameter, matching that to the data,
capital, U. There are natural questions, right?
Do you have the correct model? What if something
changed? Do you have there are, you know, a whole
laundry list of an entire sub area of statistics,
is ways that you can do to detect the correct
model from test, from just statistical testing
to COVID labor discrepancies and the entire
information criteria world that came out of
that. There's the Bayesian world, there's more
of the machine, the computation, computer science
world. So there's a lot of different ways
that you can say, How would How good does
the information flow from data to parameters? And
usually the the methods that people have come up
with you worry about, you know, robustness
to noise. How accurate is it? What is the
computational efficiency? How fast can this be
done? And usually, any method you come up with,
pick two, right? You don't get all three. And so
one of the things that's been fascinating about
this is that there are ways in which we're getting
all three of these. And here's what the example
I'm going to show. So with that kromotossky
equation here along this axis is the wall
time to do a parameter estimation. Here along the
vertical axis is the relative error of the vector,
so the norm of the error, basically, and this
is with 20% noise on a spatio temporal, chaotic
PBE. And we're in if you just try to do this in
MATLAB, you know, depending upon the real noise
realization, depending upon the parameter initial
guess you have, which, of course, then you have to
figure out what your initial guess is. You can get
anything between taking a second, if you're lucky,
all the way to hundreds of seconds, all the way
from, you know, basically 1% or so, or to 10%
error, going single digits error, all the way
up to hundreds and hundreds of percents error.
So there's really this entire spread of different
output error methods that just using standard ODE
solver or sorry, PDE solver in Matlab to try to
solve these. There's a lot of knobs your numerical
optimization. When do you stop? You know? When do
you iterate? And what do you truncate, or sorry,
when you converge? Turns out, if you use
what we're doing in the weak form, you get
a very straightforward linear algebra problem
that is taking less than a second on a laptop,
and you're getting, you know, the mean here is
really for 20% noise. You're getting far down
here, below 10% error on these parameters, which
is quite surprising, that you're able to get both
the speed, the accuracy and the robustness to
the 20% noise here. Okay, so hopefully this is,
this has whet your appetite now and that there's
a lot of interesting things that are are coming.
And you'll let me get away with my cutesy title
about the week form being stronger than you think.
But okay, so where does our story begin? Let's go
back to the 50s, and I'll show you what what they
were doing. So they would say, Okay, I have some
differential equation here. In this case, there
was odes time derivative over here. And then we
have linear and parameters. These functions here,
usually are coming from the equations of motion,
various physics based ideas. The whole concept
that they were they were attempting to do. And
then it sort of the stopped working on this area
was take, instead of solving the equation, let's
take the equation and plug the data in. And so
you can, of course, create for every data point
you sample at u1 all the way to u m, you can,
you know, you can evaluate it, all these
features, these F case that you have that
are physics based. And then you can evaluate a
vector, which is the derivatives. Now, of course,
you see, I put a little tilde here because we know
if we start taking derivatives of data, especially
if it's noisy, that's going to be a problem.
And they knew this too, right? So they said,
All right. So here's the GW minus b. Let's try to
identify the parameters in a least square sense.
That's great if it's not noisy, because it's fast,
but it's very sensitive to noise, especially if
you do a finite difference approximations here,
and even if you do smoothing, because the problem
is that you're basically projecting your data, not
onto the solution manifold. You're projecting onto
the basis for the smoothing operators, you
can still get, you know, there's well known
biases that will creep in here, which can be a
problem if you're trying to fly your plane. Okay,
so as I said, you know, advances in output, error
methods, really, this area did not receive a lot
as much development as it could have. And
by, you know, the year 2000 it was pretty
much dormant. So that's where we were for quite
a while. And then there was a paper in 2016 in
PNAS that is the Cindy method, right? The sparse
identification of domino dynamics. And why this
has sort of resurrected this area of you know, the
equation error looking at the actual when you plug
in the data into the equation, this equation
error approach is what, what Steve Brunt and
Josh Proctor and Nathan cuts did was they said,
Okay, suppose we don't know the right. Hand side.
Suppose we say, let's consider a kitchen sink.
Let's consider all these possible libraries,
a huge set of library terms here. And can we by
plugging the data in to this particular matrix
here? Can we do again, a minimization of the
least squares, but to look at the well, let's,
let's regularize it by doing sparsity. Okay, so
the idea would be, if you plug the data in here
for, say, the diffusion equation, the W vector
that you want to identify is a zero here,
a zero here, a non zero for this term, and
then a zero is for everything else. So that's,
that's the specification process that you want
to do. Okay, so this actually it's, it's, it's
really resurrected this area of equation error.
You can call it an operator learning algorithm,
if you wish. It's not quite the same as
what we think of with neural networks,
but you are literally learning the right hand
side of an evolution operation. So it is kind
of an operator learning you're just getting,
you know, the pencil and paper version of it
that you could then analyze if you wanted to. Now,
of course, the problem with the derivatives didn't
go away. That's still there. If you're doing
any type of finite difference approximation,
it's very easy to see that the step size in the
denominator is going to, you know, destroy the
variance of this estimator. If you just make the
assumption that you have data plus noise and you
try to do a finite difference approximation on
it, it's just your expectation, expected value
of the of this is just going to blow up awfully.
So Moreover, what about, you know, the independent
of the noise? What if you have a shock wave
and you have data being taken on that? Well,
your solution may not be smooth, so immediately
we start thinking about the weak form. And so
what happened was one of the things that when we
were being very frustrated, and I was being very
frustrated at looking at some of these, you know,
model selection methods and parameter inference
methods, and if there was anything we could do
that would be better, it occurred to me maybe we
could do something with an integral transform to
this. And then sort of, Dan said, How about the
weak form? And this is really what, where this
came from. And so if we look at this, okay, so
this is a more abstract version, right? So here's
your using multi index notation. So there's the,
just think about this, the time derivative on the
left. And this is whatever derivatives you need.
And then these are potentially non linear terms.
So that's, that's the form, at least. That's what
I'm going to restrict to right now, we don't
really have to be that restrictive, but let's
just deal with this, because it's easier to work
through. So the idea here is, you take your PDE,
and, of course, you interpret it in the weak
sense. So you need a test function right now.
Why are we doing this? Well, we're doing it
because we can pull the derivatives off of the
data and just by integration by parts, place
it on the test function. We of course, choose
test functions that are compactly supported over a
finite region, so you have, you know, zero values,
and then you set it up with zero derivatives at
the end points. And you don't have to worry about
the evaluation part of integration by parts. And
you're just pulling derivatives off of the off of
the data itself. We get around that whole problem
with the with the discretization and the finite
difference operators causing problems with noisy
data. And this equation is the equation. So we're
actually now trying to solve for these parameters
with a simply transformed equation. Now. So what
is, what does this sort of look like? You can, of
course, then create your B vector, your G matrix,
and again, you're back in this sparse regression
problem, but now you're robust to noise,
and that's really the core of what's
what's happened here. Are there any any
quick questions so far before? Because this is,
this is sort of the core of what I'm going to
build on. Yeah, any questions,
you can unmute yourself and ask,
Hi, Professor, I
have a quick question. Could you please explain
how noise affects, how the derivatives affect
get affected in the presence of noise? I
didn't understand that part quite, quite well.
So if you So, here's on this side. Well, there's
a time derivative here. There's also, you know,
first second space derivatives, or however many
derivatives you want, as potential library terms
that you could select for. So, just as I
mentioned, so if it's diffusion. You only
want this one, right? You want to do this sparse
regression so you get that. But the problem is,
you have data. Which is the U, right? This
capital U is your data. What happens when you
plug the data into the equation? We're not solving
the equation. We're completely bypassing that,
that idea. We are simply taking the original, an
original equation. In this case, we're making it a
super large because it's got all these potential
terms in there, but you still have to plug the
data in to be able to minimize this, this least
squares cost function, so it's a residual of the
equation itself. And so the problem is, how
do you do that if you have noisy data? So.
Is that answering your question?
Yeah, thank you. Okay, and
there's another question by
Amit in the chat he's asking,
Will this work if you have first
and second time derivatives?
Yes. I mean, so we have gone all the way up
to I mean, fourth derivatives are no problem.
I'll actually show a plot later on where we
nail the fourth derivative fairly, really,
really accurately. Yeah, it's it's limited by
the library you choose. So whatever library
you you decide you need, here, that's it. And
we've done things all the way up to hundreds
and even 1000 terms in library. You if you
go too big, like if you decide, oh, well,
I want to have you to the 10th power as a
potential term in the library. You can run
into numerical problems where vectors that
are sort of super large dominate everything,
and so you have rank problems, but, but, you
know, then there's a question of, do you really
need you to the 10th as a library you want to
reject? Sorry, library term you want to reject,
usually just talk to the physicist or the
biochemist or whoever you're dealing with,
as far as what's, what's a reasonable set and
maybe go one above that. You know, it's sort of
a little more ad hoc, but it's still you just
try not to get too big for numerical reasons.
Okay, all right, I'll
okay. So Right? So again, we're back to
solving this sparse regression problem. Okay,
so what do these things look like? Well, they're
just test functions. They're just test functions
that are zero at the endpoints and derivatives
are zero at the endpoints. And then, of course,
you can take a derivative of the test function
instead of taking a derivative of the data. And
you can kind of squint at this. This is just
the, you know, phi and phi prime here. And you
can see this is actually, like almost a continuous
analog of a finite difference operator. I mean,
it's a negative of it, right? But, but that's,
that's really what this is doing here. Is that
integral transform is it's not just smoothing
the data like this type of a kernel would be,
but it's also a derivative smoother when
after integration by parts. So, of course,
there's also these, these questions that come up,
which are at the end of the day. And this is the,
this is the important part. These are answerable
questions using very conventional things in
numerical analysis of numerical linear algebra
statistics that have come out in the last 70
years. What's the spectrum of these, you know,
these types of analyzes. So there's like,
this is something that is understandable from
one end to the other. Sort of my point here,
if you want to see the sort of a brief, sort
of high level overview, we got an article on
the front page of SIAM News in October. It's some
nice, pretty pictures there. But, so that's the
bigger picture here. But at the end of the day,
this, you know, it has been around for a while,
and I went over it a little bit in the in the
SIAM News mentioned the 54 articles, but it's, you
know, people didn't stop in 54 like they continued
developing this. There's actually a companion,
sort of archive preprint that goes through a lot
of the more citations in the history of this. And
what people had come up with was everything from
trig functions to various piece wise polynomials.
This is the one that completely independently.
We didn't know about this when we started,
but this is the one we came up with also, and
then a variety of other people using Hermite
polynomials. There's three different frequencies
of trig functions. And then there's something down
here with cooks. Cas is cosine plus sine, and then
this is basically using a Hartley transform. So
there's a variety of things people have chosen
to try, but we have some other ideas. So yes,
there's a history here, but it was really dormant
by 2000 and then the archive preprint, that's the
companion for this. I am news. I go into this
sort of what's what's happening here. Okay,
so let's see, so what, what is possible now with
this method, well, the Lawrence equation. This
is sort of everyone's favorite chaotic attractor
here. Add 10% noise to this, and you get the red,
fuzzy bits here. And in we can get less than
1% error with 10% noise on this. And do it in,
I mean fractions and fractions of a second. I
mean, why? Because it's going completely to the
realm of linear algebra, numerical linear algebra,
MATLAB is amazing at this, right? And I'm just
doing this in MATLAB. There's nothing, nothing
super fancy about this that's going on. But
the question is, you know, when you think about
model discovery for, say, the Lawrence equation,
how in the world can you even compare? I mean,
I'm able to solve this threshold or prune the
the incorrect terms from like 100 or several 100
term library get the correct Lawrence equation,
get the parameters with less than a percent error
in a fraction of a second. Whereas, if I tried to
just fit this using a standard system ID toolbox,
I must admit I actually did let MATLAB run this,
and it ran for like a week, trying to fit and
solve and fit and estimate and it. Had never
figured out what the parameters were with 10%
noise for this amount of it just it took forever.
So that's great. The so we have a whole, the whole
paper, and multi scale modeling, the simulation
I did this an ODEs, and then PDS, we have a
computational physics paper. And you know, this
works exactly. Not only the noise is dealt with,
but also the shock waves are dealt with. And this
is just burgers, right? Or this is burgers.
And for several 100 of these carpet pictures,
we can go all the way up to 99% sorry,
100% error. So that's, you know,
basically the noise to signal ratio. And you can
end up with 99% of those hundreds of experiments,
we correctly get that there is only this
term. Okay, sure, it's not perfect two and
a half percent. So it's not exactly of all those
hundreds of experiments, it's not always exactly
minus one. But you know, the worst is two
and a half percent off, which is pretty nice,
of course. Camera, since key, same thing, and
this is now the equation discovery. What I was
talking about was the parameter estimation, if
we assume we know these three terms are here,
and what's happening now is we go all the way up
to 100% error and 96% of the equation. Other the
experiments, we correctly determine just these
three terms, 30% error on the parameters. But
at that point, it's sort of, you're pretty happy
that you've gotten the three terms you want. So,
and that's the max overall, the overall the
runs we did. Okay, so what? What is, what's,
where's the magic come from? Like, that's, it's
interesting that you can just take data and come
up with an equation, even if it's noisy. And if
you look at the the general computational physics,
we have other examples, and I'll talk about those
a little bit. But like, you know, Navier Stokes,
reaction, diffusion, reaction diffusions, these
are all well within the framework that we can deal
with. So what is that? Where does this come from?
And here's something that was really fascinating.
I'll talk a little bit about this later also.
And this was what we realized in the MMS paper.
So this is just a Vanderpool oscillator.
So the standard nonlinear oscillator here,
if you look at a test function, that's a piecewise
polynomial. So you've got roots at A and minus a,
and then you have, you know, it's sort of a
compact that supported so outside of, you know,
whatever the so you have your middle of the day of
the test function, then outside of a or minus a,
every place else that's all zero. And then we
use that, you know, kind of just shift the test
function throughout the domain to create our
equations, but you still have to choose this p
right as the power of the polynomial. One of the
fascinating things we realized was, for the no
noise case, if you crank up the P, you actually
get the accuracy of your ODE solver. Like, if you
could do better than this, this will keep going
down. And we've tried this with higher precision
things. And basically where this is coming from is
the fact that you need to do these inner products,
right? So these are approximations of integrals.
Of course, they're discrete approximations of
integrals. But here's the thing, we're just using
the trapezoid rule. Now, the trapezoid rule has
a superpower, right? It's a superpower that, if
you have a periodic function, and it turns into,
you know, periodic with you do the periodic
extension, you have basically something that's
ordered delta t to the p plus one power is the
error in doing this regression here. Sorry,
this, this residual for the left side, you know,
minus the right side. Basically you get order
T, a delta t to the p plus one. So if you keep
cranking up the order on the polynomial of your
your piecewise, piecewise polynomial for your test
function, you will get better and better results,
because your numerical error is going down in the
no noise case, right? So this is not something I'd
seen before in terms of parameter estimation or
equation discovery. This. This is sort of, you
know, basically, give it, give us an indication
that maybe we were on to something interesting.
And so what you can actually do, and we did this
a little bit later, you can take that residual,
which is, of course, you know, GW minus R.
Oops, that should be B, not R, sorry, GW,
minus b, so that's the residual. But of course,
you know, you can plug in the data and for an
arbitrary vector parameters, what happens when
you take truth plus noise? Well, here's the
interesting part. This is something you know,
just some Taylor expansions, etc. You can break
this down into the part of the residual is due
to the noise. So if noise goes away, of course,
then this term disappears the part of the residual
due to having the W not be correct. So of course,
if you, if you plug in the correct W, then
this is going to go away. But then there's
this other term having to do with the numerical
discretization, okay? And so what happened is,
it's actually the numerical disposition that
is driving this dominating. In this case,
you know, of course, if you get enough noise,
then this term dominates. And then, of course,
if you're far enough away from the true solution,
then that term dominates. But it was really
interesting, this was, this is numerical analysis
question at this point. And so given the data,
we came up with a basic. A Fourier transform,
discrete Fourier transform. Way to approximate
what the derivative or what the error in the
the integral is. And the two black lines are
kind of like you can bound where the numerical
error is. And then what this is also showing is,
as you increase, sorry, the horizontal axis
here is the radius of a test function. The
vertical axis is the error in the what you can
call it the error in the parameter estimate.
And so you can see that the the numerical is
the upper bound black line, the lower bound of
the of the numerics on that that integration
error. And then as you add noise, of course,
the floor gets brought up. So green is a little
bit of noise, red is more noise. Blue is a lot of
noise. But the important thing is, what you can
do is you can choose a test function now, where,
which is a transition, and it's away from the
numerical error into the noise, so you don't have
to worry about this term here. Or you can minimize
the the impact of that term. And that's, you know,
that's what we've discovered, this balance between
noise and numerics. Okay. So another thing that
has been really interesting here is you can also
look at this. If you have something with lots of
spectrum frequency, you don't just look at like
a local test function. You can actually look at
a global perspective that am I matching the
spectrum correctly? So if I have blue as the
truth for Coronavirus in ski, noise is red is my
my noisy data that's added on top of that, if I
look at the the Fourier transform of the of the
data, I can figure out, you know, try to figure
out a region where the noise is starting to I want
to get rid of the noise above a certain level. And
if I use that to pick my wave number, and I can
then translate that back into the choice of a test
function, and the the shape of the test function,
how fast it's decaying. What you see down here is,
is basically the fourth derivative of data.
So the red is, of course, the sort of blue is,
of course, the true fourth derivative, true weak
fourth derivative. And then the red is the noisy
fourth derivative, noisy the weak derivative, weak
fourth derivative of noisy data. And you can see,
I mean, I don't, you can just they're lying
on top of each other, right? So they're,
they're not perfect, but it's that. That's the
reason that that term is not a problem taking a
fourth derivative of noisy data, okay, one of the
other things that has been incredibly helpful is,
and this is one of the reasons, I think, why, if
you naively plow ahead with this method without
thinking about computational concerns, you'll get
the wrong answer. So if you have 50% noise on KdV,
so this is a corporate degrees with some solitons
that are interacting with each other. The issue
is, if you look at it, you've got, you know,
the time axis is on the order of 10 to the minus
three. The space axis is order one, and the value
of the solution is order three. That's six orders
of magnitude separating the numbers. In each of
these cases, if you just plow ahead and form G
without thinking, you're going to get a condition
number on the order of 10 to the 26 that's going
to be challenging for you know, IEEE, double
precision floating point arithmetic. However,
if you rescale these so that they are sort of
all on the same scale, you can actually drop your
condition number 10 to the sixth, which is not
perfect, but it's much better than it's basically
matching your 10 to the minus three to the 10
to the three separation, as opposed to something
that's just, you know, off the chart, awful one
won't actually tell you anything. So scaling is
important to make sure you normalize things.
So what's the what's the punchline here? Well,
so we went through and chose a whole laundry
list of very challenging PDS. Gave them some
reasonable libraries with certain number of non
zero terms in this, burgers, COVID Since key, KDB,
non linear. Schrodinger, Navier, Stokes, porous
media, sign, Gordon reaction diffusion. So all
things that exhibit different kinds of shock
waves, stiff systems, spirals, oscillatory
behavior, chaos. You know these kind of things.
Nothing takes more than 75 seconds on a nice old,
creaky laptop from over 10 years ago. So in some
sense, it really makes sense, right? Because it's
just a linear regression problem. You're just
solving Ax equals b, it's it ends up, you know,
it's not the small system you do have to worry
about. You know, G is 11,000 by 181 in a reaction
diffusion system. But it still is to be able to
correctly learn that that is a reaction diffusion
spiral wave system in 75 seconds. Seems very
interesting and a compelling result that if
you have data like that, would be something to
consider using this method on to see what comes
out of it. So, okay, so that's all in the journal
computational physics article. And again, sort of,
what do you what in the world? Do you mean by
comparison? Like, if you're trying to do like,
some AIC type comparison, you have to propose
all different combinations of methods and solve
those PDS, like, it's, it's, it's, this is a
completely different way to think about model.
Discovery. Okay, so what becomes possible?
So here's something that is really kind of
interesting. We chose to look at, of all things,
cell migration. And there are actually some really
interesting directions you can go with this,
in terms of, well, like even birds and drones,
if you're trying to discover something about
how drones or what rules drones are using to
fly in which directions they're going, this
is actually a framework you can start thinking
about it. So we chose cell migration because
I have a project with someone who traces,
basically to take a sheet of skin cells and then
they cut away part of it and watch the cells to
migrate into the wound. And so usually there are
PDE models that describe these in terms of chemo
taxes and other types of just traditional PDE
modeling. What we did was a cell by cell model.
So this is interacting particle system, so you
have what are the rules that the cell is using?
This is an attraction, repulsion, force potential.
There's an alignment potential, and there's a drag
potential. Now we haven't gone further than
saying, what is the functional form of this,
this function here, but that's sort of pushing the
phenomenology question one layer further away from
you that then you could go to now the biochemistry
and say, you know, if I come up with this shape of
a potential for a cell in terms of what it's using
to sense its environment and choose where it goes.
You immediately have a more concrete conversation
with a with a biochemist that talks about this.
So what do these things look like? Well, so to be
completely fair, there's a lot of artificial data
here. We started with experimental data, but there
were some you know, these potentials are inspired
by experimental data. We haven't we've just
gotten some new data sets that we're going to
be trying. But the idea here what we're going to
use, which, again, was inspired by analyzing real
data. This is a attraction repulsion potential,
which is basically saying the cell doesn't get
What does not want to get too close or in front
of or behind, the cells that are moving, they
can hang out next to each other in like a row,
that's okay, and kind of march forward in a row.
That's a perfectly fine movement. Over here, it's
saying that whatever the cell is in front of it, I
want to align with that. So if I see a cell going
like this, this one back here is going to try to
follow it as it moves in whichever direction it's
moving. It could care less about what's going on
behind it. So given that these were inspired by,
you know, the first pass of data, what we did was,
then we created a bunch of artificial cells. And
here's the thing that's really fascinating. So
we made a heterogeneous mixture of cells that had
different potentials, and we let them, you know,
run around. That's all the gray trajectories
here. So we assume we had gray trajectories,
then for each individual cell, we learned the
potentials for that cell and then given for each
cell. So there was hundreds and hundreds of cells,
and then each of them had their own potentials. We
were able to use a ad hoc classification scheme
and recover the fact that we had actually put
three different cell lines or three different cell
types based on their potential behaviors in that
mixture. This is just one. I don't think this
is all, but this is a certain one of the one of
the cell types is the teal one. And what you can
see here is that as the cell moves along on the
black is the data we can learn those potentials
correctly, that if you it's it's literally lying
right on top of it, and it includes the ability to
do, I mean, this is the 90 degree turn followed by
180 degree turn based upon the nearby cells. And
you can see, we're pretty much nailing these data
correctly. So we've, we're excited about some of
the new data that that we're getting to analyze
from the from the lab, but this is the kind
of thing that can happen, is now you can say,
Alright, put down a bunch of cells, have them
grow, and now I can literally, based on their
trajectories, I can discover what is the sub
populations, which is kind of the biologists
were pretty excited about this, and just to show
you what it looks like, so here's three this is
sort of the subsets of the gray trajectories
here of all the cells. And we have, you know,
based upon how well that trajectory predicts
which way something's going, you can actually,
you know, it's a normally distributed error. You
can actually separate and say, Okay, if I use the
wrong model, they're over here. And here's all the
right model match to the cells. And so they can
literally be split into into sub populations that
are of different cell types. So let's see. Yeah,
so this was three cells. One of the things that's
interesting here is that these were completely
unlabeled trajectories. So we didn't go in saying,
Oh, I know that this is from this cell type. We
were they were completely not. No knowledge
about them, aside from, they were coming from
an interacting particle system. Okay, the whole
idea here is, we're trying to build a framework
that would be foundational tools for biological,
digital twins, right? I mean, the whole that,
the next step in the in the funding that we have,
what we're doing is with these trajectories,
we're also then my collaborator can label certain
pathways inside the cell. So now you're going to
be able to learn an ODE for each individual cell
that describes the biochemistry as well as the
interacting particle system, so how it is choosing
which way to go. And so you're now coupling
biochemistry with mechanical taxes and movement.
Okay, alright, so that's one one application.
Another application, as I kind of showed a
little bit of this in the beginning, is parameter
estimation. And so why this is different? Well,
so here's the thing, if we have the basically
matrix G, which has data in it, times the vector
w parameters we want, and we have the vector b,
which has also data in it, this is, you know,
yeah, you can just solve the normal equations,
right? This is where we learn linear algebra.
Very, very simple and straightforward. The problem
here is, this is not a traditional, ordinarily
squares problem. You have to think about this,
and you have to be very careful, because you have
your data is corrupting the matrix and the vector.
And the picture that shows you, this is
this normally we think about, if you put a
straight line through something, you have vertical
errors, right? That would be like errors just in
B. The problem here is that we have both errors in
the horizontal and the vertical direction. If you
notice, if you know something about the ratio of
errors in the different terms, then you call it a
totally squares problem. And this is a very well
known and well studied Eugene Golub has a bunch
of papers on this that totally squares numerics,
but that's a different issue. So, so the way that
we came up to do this is, effectively, if you
look at the residual, the of your truth here,
it's actually normally distributed, but you need
to know the parameters that get the covariance,
so we have an iterative updating scheme, just
reweighting the covariance, sort of our first pass
at this creates a matrix here. The important thing
is that when you do this, you have to do a Taylor
expansion to get this. What you need in here is
a Jacobian of your library. Okay, so all these
other things, this is bookkeeping, you know, if
you have different dimensions of variables, etc,
here's your test functions choices. The important
thing is buried down in there, you actually need
to know the derivatives of your library terms,
and then you can get an accurate estimate for
the parameters and the covariance that comes
along with that. So just an example here. This is
facinagumo. So this is the standard oscillation
ODE. You oscillation ODE from neuroscience,
if you do traditional, non linear least squares,
where you do forward solves, guess a parameter,
solve, check, guess a parameter, solve, that kind
of thing. You're over here because you have so
many knobs that you need to turn the tolerance of
the solver, the truncate, the stopping criteria
for the optimization, all these things, and
it can take hundreds of seconds just for a
simple ODE with 5% noise. Whereas, you know the
difference between in time and this is, horizontal
axis is time, vertical axis is error, again, the
difference in this time and this time is probably,
did you hit reload on your email and check it
right? Because that's, that's, that's what you can
do. And you're talking about, you know, seconds or
fractions of a second, depending on how you code
it up. And of course, you know, yeah, there is
a difference in the specific errors you get out,
but those are that's realization based, right?
It's the specific, noisy data that you have,
and where was it? Where was it noisy? Okay, one
of the really awesome parts about this is that,
since you are living back in statistics and
regression world, you get, sort of your UQ on
the parameters for free, right? Because it's just
what's inference on the parameters. You can get,
you know, obviously the this is sort of the scaled
covariance matrix, but you can say what's the,
you know, relationship between the various
parameters. That's all part of the traditional
statistics. Okay, so one more application here,
which is what is part of the mimic the Department
of Energy proposal that this center that we're
that young, Sue and I are a part of. And here's
two examples from that. Because now, when you
have this idea of sparse regression, you know,
maybe it's, maybe you have an equation and,
you know, the Hamiltonian and all these things,
but at the end of the day, it would have been so
complicated that you can't do anything with it.
So what we've been looking at here is reduced
order models. And so what you see on the left
is a reduced order model where the Hamiltonian is
being maintained, basically. So you're taking some
higher dimensional system and you're collapsing
it. In this case, I think it was a non linear
coupled oscillators in eight dimensions. This was
collapsed to four, so you're only seeing three of
the variables, but there's actually a fourth one.
But what's really nice is, by doing that process,
there's still some knobs. You can choose
which scale you want to look at, while keeping
your Hamiltonian more or less accurate. So the
basically, the original curve is this black line,
which is bumping around in this phase space. And
you can see there's sort of oscillations and a
scale that's going into and out of the screen,
and then there's a larger scale oscillation going
around this orbit. You can choose. Your scale such
that you either are stuck here and you can just be
on the fast scale, you know, oscillating here, or
you can choose the lower, the longer time scale to
go around the orbit where you've collapsed in that
direction. And this was published this summer.
The other place you can do reduced order model
is a much more computational thing. That is what
came out of young Suze group with this latent
space dynamics inference for identification.
And so this case is where, say you want to train
your model. So this is, these are two parameters
related to the initial condition for solving,
I think this is 1d or 2d burgers. And you can
train your basically, your compression, your auto
encoder, if you want, or a pod, whatever you want,
train it on the black squares, which are
parameter combinations. But the question is,
can you create a reduced order model where
you can pick a different, arbitrary parameter
in this grid or elsewhere, and get a correct,
correct reduced order model that then you can
expand back to the full order model. And but
you're doing all your solving on the reduced
order model. And so here's the thing is that the
original way of dealing with with Los D, this
latent space dynamics identification was to use,
well, basically, ordinarily, squares combined with
finite difference operators from the sort of plain
vanilla Cindy. If you use the weak form Cindy,
it turns out that you can get it down to the
resolution of your projection operation. And these
are, you can't really see the numbers here, sorry.
They're like three and 4% which is basically as
good as it's going to get based upon the auto
encoder and or the the pod projection of using
only so many singular values. And so, of course,
you know even, and here's the thing, 50% noise on
the original data you get down to a model that's
giving you 100% speed up and only 5% error in your
predictions. So it's, it's really quite compelling
in terms of how it can help. Okay, let's see. So I
want to make sure I get one little thing in here.
The really awesome part about like this, this
is actually something that has really been quite
interesting for us. And just just we can actually
say what's the class of models that in the limited
continuum data, we are basically with probability
one, asymptotically, we will recover the correct
model. And so you have asymptotic consistency in
the model learning process. So if you have a model
which is on this form right here, so linear and
bilinear, the highest power it can be is quadratic
and an individual variable, and this is a huge
number of different all the equations I've
shown today all fall in this category. If you,
if you try to learn it, and you learn the wrong
model, add more data, asymptotically, you will be
able to get it. And we have some some results that
say exactly what that looks like, so at the end,
so there's like, a critical noise level,
stability, tolerance. So this isn't all a I don't
want to go too long here, but that we have a very
nice theorem that is coming out in ima numerical
analysis that Dan did some amazing work with
the concentrations of the probability here. And
basically, here's a picture of what it looks like.
This isn't criminal citizens key. It's kind of
close, though, and it's it's got things like six
derivatives, so it's sort of the same ilk. This is
the picture of the solution, where x and then time
goes up, and you can see it very quickly gets all
sorts of messy and chaotic. This is kind of what
a test function looks like. And so we're kind of
taking that magnet, smudging magnifying glass and
kind of passing it through the domain to create
our large linear system to solve. And this is, of
course, what the noisy version looks like. As you
more or less go from left to right here, you're
adding more and more data, higher resolution of
data in here, you're sort of decreasing the step
sizes in t and x. And what you can see is that you
know for the highest level noise, so noise ratio
one to 100% you can't do it on a test function.
That is, the data is 13 by 13. That's too small.
But by the time you get over to 100 by 100 you're
really starting to recover. The probability of
you recovering this model completely correct in
the terms is approaching one, okay. And then, of
course, you know, for less noise, then it's easier
to recover the correct model. And then, so we have
this, and this is surprisingly, a huge fraction of
mathematical physics fits in this category. So we
can, we can discover many, many things. There's,
there are, there's, we even have some corollaries
to this, where if you add extra terms, like trig
functions, you'll still get the correct recovery.
It's just going to be biased as the parameters,
but you'll still have the correct terms. Okay,
okay. Then in the last few minutes here, I want
to talk about. Forthcoming work. So this is what
I showed at the beginning. We've got parameter
estimation, PDS that's sort of in progress.
There's another angle on this that's also in
progress, but really fascinating because there's
one kind of big land mine sitting in the middle
of this that is an important feature that needs to
be addressed. And it's that you need to have data
on all of the variables that are going to go into
this equation. Error. Okay? So just as an example,
if you wanted to to estimate parameters or
learn equations for a epidemiology model,
right, you don't get to know the number of people
who are susceptible every day during a pandemic,
you don't get to know the number of people who
are infected and asymptomatic. Maybe you have
some guesses in terms of the data, but you don't.
You don't have a really good what you do have are
hospitalizations. You have really good data
on people every day. You can get a census. The
Department of Public Health would would have
that. And so the question is, how do you use
these methods? And, I mean, here's another example
where you're giving somebody a some therapy in the
blood. You can measure the blood and see how well
it's working, but you can't sample somebody's,
you know, liver or other organs to see if the
drugs getting in there. But you can write down
differential equation model, and then you do
some okay, I can take samples on the blood and
what you do is use some tricks from differential
algebra to reduce this to an equation just in the
observed variable, and then you can do things.
And so this is just a plot showing actually,
if you have the noise increasing in your blood
samples, you can still get pretty good estimates
of the parameters of k1, 2k, two, one, and this
sort of uptake numbers. So there this sort of
work in progress. We're trying to basically solve
that problem using some some nifty differential
algebra tricks. Okay, so time summary, so, you
know, I think about this more broadly speaking,
as operator learning. What we're learning the
form of the equation, and that is our W Cindy
algorithm that does that parameter inference is
we're calling it Wendy, we perform estimation
of nominal dynamics. And we are really excited,
because we are actually getting a lot of these
race properties of robustness, accuracy and the
computational efficiency. And most important. So
there's two things, the computational efficiency.
You can run these things on laptops. So this is
really fast. If you choose to do this on a GPU,
you can actually recast a step in the middle as a
one layer in a convolutional neural network, and
you can actually get another order of magnitude
speed up simply because of the embarrassingly
parallel feature of doing that. And so actually,
you've been running it on GPU goes even faster,
not because you're using some network or anything,
just because of the mathematics of GPUs and the
way they work with the cores. One of the things
I'll mention before the end here, there has been a
nice ecosystem that has started to develop around
this. There's sort of become an awareness that
the weak form is really this has some compelling
noise robustness results. And so even in the
group at the University of Washington, they
have come up with an alternative strategy, which
is called ensembling that gets that helps with
the noise. But it turned out it was fascinating,
if you did the weak form, the ensembling that was
actually the best of their of all their methods
in their paper, there's even some people at MIT
doing mixed integer optimization. There's ways to
improve the sparse regression suit. Sun ha Kang
at Georgia Tech is leading groups and doing
some of that. There's even some really nice
theoretical results, basically casting this in
a reproducing Colonel Hilbert space. And the W,
C, D algorithm is sort of projecting in a way
that is accurate, etc. And then one final thing
I'll mention, which I thought was really, really
fascinating that I this is a paper I just saw.
There's a group in California at the basically
City of Hope, I think is the research center
down in Southern California. And they were
taking dynamic MRI images and recovering
spatially varying perfusion coefficients that
may not sound may not be confusing is Why is
that interesting? Well, basically, if you
give somebody a some sort of a tracer or a
contrast and watch it perfuse through, say,
a tumor, those are going to have different
perfusion parameters than a than the surrounding
tissue. And so you're, you're very quickly able,
from Dynamic MRI and images to reconstruct exactly
where a tumor might be. And so this is some,
this is a really interesting application. They're
using our method to do to do this. I was just kind
of blown away when I saw some results. Okay,
so acknowledgements here, of course, you know,
there have been nice support from variety
of funding agencies. And then these are,
of course, as we all know, these are the people
who did the real work, the graduate students.
And I must have to call out Dan, because that's
really the work came out of his dissertation,
and we've been collaborating ever since on this.
He. Now a director's postdoc fellow at LANL, and
then just to references that we have here. So if
you want these sort of 30,000 foot view of this,
there's the SIAM News article. We have a chapter
in the handbook of numerical analysis that goes
into some of the technical details. This is what
we've managed to put out there with ODEs, PDS,
interacting particle systems, online
learning, the parameter estimation,
reduced order model, so sort of it's really been
quite productive for us to look at from this,
this point of view. And then there's been
some more recent proposals, actually,
this one, the reduced fourth register model.
Paper has been accepted. And then there's,
these are the two things that are in
progress right now, nonlinear parameters,
and then also estimation for the PDE s and I think
that's, that's all my that's the talk. Thank you.
Oh, fascinating, wonderful, very nice.
Thank you so much for the nice talk,
David. Let's thank Speaker. Let's have
a 20 sessions. If you have questions,
please unmute and ask questions. I have one
question, well, I'm several questions, but
the first question I would ask would be, you know
that i i I totally agree with you, David, there
will be so much more broad applications where
this weeks in D can be used. I mean, you showed
some bio laws, the applications and plasma and and
other partial differential equations or dynamics.
Any other applications in mind? If you have
funding, I really want to apply this too, sure,
well, so we actually so part of the NIH money
is to do stochastic differential equations too,
and we have a couple of this paper right
here does some stochastic differential
equations. We did deterministic, interacting
particle systems in here. So we didn't,
we didn't do any stochastic ones.
And I think this one down, no,
not that one. This one here is an ecology example
which does have some stochastics in it as well,
and why you want to go there?
Well. So if you think about doing parameter
estimation for stochastic differential equations,
a lot of the time, you need to do a
large number of realizations of this,
of the solutions to sample it. And when
you are if you have data, either for like,
an individual particle and is wandering
around, we can do some estimation there.
Or if you have a collection of particles that I
didn't have it in this talk, but we've actually
done some some things with, you know, having,
like, a couple 100 particles wandering around,
and you can very quickly identify the drift
and diffusion coefficients. I mean, this,
some of the preliminary versions of this
go all the way back to the the the first
week form papers from 2019, 2021, that kind
of stuff. But, yeah, so that's, so that's,
that's an area that's really compelling because
it's sort of this automatic upscaling. Is what
you're kind of doing to get the the parameters
you need. Is that answering your question,
yeah, can it be somehow useful for the noise
data as well, stochastic differential? Sure,
yeah. So that's so, so it's a, it's a
question of what's swamping, what right,
and what's the dominant How much do you know?
Like, do you is it just Brownian motion? And
then your observation is noisy. Also, that's
something you I mean, you would have to do some
analysis to turn the crank on it. The The nice
part about it, though, is that you're again,
dealing with a statistical regression system.
So there are, there's nominee regression,
you can deal, you can do things with there's
linear regression. There's these errors and
variables problems. So there's a lot of it's, it's
a well, tried path that simply, I feel like a lot
of the times we go look up some advanced things
in literature, and then, not that the theorems
and the papers write themselves, but they are
available to be discovered. And it's less, it's,
it's just, it's just a, you know, it's what you're
trained for when you do applied math. Basically,
all right, we have Amit. Amit, if
you can, yeah, ask your question.
Thanks. So thanks, David, very nice talk. I think
one particular application is what we are trying
to do in our group. We are in the physics
division. We are trying to generate continuum
scale models directly from atomistic data. And the
The hope is that complexity associated with the
non equilibrium processes, effect of chemistry,
all of these can be been called. Operated into
the continuum scheme models that we hope to learn
from atomistic data. And I think naturally they
come out to be stochastic differential equation.
So not we initially, we thought they'll they'll
just be PDS, but it seems now that they'll
be SDS, and the question, or the couple of
questions that come up the following, and one one
of them, I actually had mentioned, what happens
if you have higher order time derivatives present
in your dictionary. And the second thing is that,
and you showed a lot of examples, but I wonder
if you can comment on the ability to learn a non
local terms. I mean differential equations that
have an integral operator with a non local kernel.
How would noise in the input data affect the
ability to reliably learn such non local terms?
Okay. I don't have a direct answer for you in
terms of the non local. I know we have done
non local terms in this paper here. We did sort
of local and non local learning of the terms.
Now we we made some assumptions about what they
look like, but we definitely have done that in
terms of the impact of noise. I mean, you're
going to be able to compute because, again,
this is coming from when you burrow right down to
the actual computation you end up doing. It's a
regression. And so you can compute like Cramer
Rao bounds on how accurate your estimates are
going to be. And in some sense, we don't really
care whether or not it's local or non local,
as long as you have data to support that. So one
of the things that is pretty critical go back to
this here, here, so for this particular
trajectory here, like it's by itself,
right? And so you don't have a lot of
interactions with the nearby particles
or the nearby cells there. And so this is a
very challenging trajectory to learn. And so
that was why our ad hoc classification scheme
started with the trajectories that had a lot of
information content and then said, Okay, well,
what if we use one of these trajectories here?
Do we still get the same or one of these models
here? Do we still get the same trajectory? And
so I think you're going to run into a question
of for the non local interactions, especially,
do you do you have data that supports
the existence of a non local interaction,
and sort of the just, just for learning.
It is that sort of answering your question?
Sure, I think you are. You're pointing to
a critical issue which we are facing in a
different problem. And the issue is about the
diversity of the of the training data itself.
How do we ensure that it's uniformly
distributed and is rich enough? Yeah,
I think I completely understand.
Okay, okay, perhaps we can often
this is something very relevant to
what we are trying to, okay, great.
I mean, I there's, there are. I have seen a
paper where they did some quantum hydrodynamics,
trying to upscale it was, I don't know if it was
data, but it was definitely atomistic simulations.
And I'm happy to follow up our email and send
you that the article I know about. There's also
an IPAM workshop coming up next fall that
I'm helping to organize on electrochemistry
and basically trying to learn models for
electrochemical interactions and such. And
I can connect you with that that world as well.
If you, if that's of interest, sure. Thank you.
Awesome. Cool. Any other questions? I
mean, it's five after 11, but if you have
questions, I'm sure David is happy to
stay longer. No. All right. If not,
let's thank our speaker, David and for
the wonderful talk. And I'm sure if you
have other questions, you'll be happy
to get an email from you guys please
follow up, happy to chat about any of the
applications or the methods and such, and
also, David welcomes you know, future
collaboration with you guys as well. So
please contact David. Well, with that,
let me start the record button. Do.